hi everyone my name is Tim rechamber and
this is Tamara's never seen it I am
watching screwed I have a complicated
movie relationship with mr. Bill Murray
there's some some real hits and some
real misses so I'm I'm excited for this
one I know a lot of people like this one
I'm interested to see how it holds up it
was made in the 80s it's a comedy I've
not had the best luck with let's do it
[Music]
okay I have some unpopular opinions from
someone who didn't grow up watching Bill
Murray movies I think the head or I can
feel the votes from here I know that
Bill Murray is beloved by everyone and I
I love that I love who people love other
people such a fun thing how great good
but I didn't grow up with Bill Murray
movies and I don't understand the appeal
everything I say I'm just gonna end with
the cringe so that his deadpan like I
really like famously deadpan character
that he plays in everything it was like
a new thing then and now it's just like
I said so overdone like everyone wanted
to do what he was doing so me now going
back and seeing both things they aren't
as fresh as we probably were when they
first came out and so I don't love it I
would love to see him play a part that
was just all really fun and good and
nice and great not a complete dick for
most of the movie I'm so sorry I was
gonna hate me oh god I didn't love this
film I didn't think it was fun enough to
warrant the the the lead character being
such a jerk the entire time it just
didn't like payoff enough for me at the
end I know a lot of people like this and
I think I am coming at it with a very
harsh tone but that's just how I feel I
mean it started off and I was like oh
it's the same jerk from Groundhog Day
I've talked to some people about this
where there's the argument that's like
well that was an 80s thing like you just
don't understand because it's an 80s
thing
I understand character development I
understand characters and I understand
what I like and don't like I understand
if you grew up with him like you'd let
you like that but like I will say though
the spirits that visit him are so cool I
loved the effects I loved the makeup in
this I wrote oh my god his ex is cute as
hell he doesn't deserve you girl the
whole film you go through it and every
time you see her it's clear that she's
still very much in love with him and
it's like why why it would have been way
more interesting to me to have her not
still be so like a head over hit like
obviously head over heels for him like
she still has feelings but like he needs
to earn it back she's so caring and
beautiful and why why why she comes to
visit him because he calls her because
he sees the first ghost his old boss
whose makeup is super cool and he's like
trying to impress her but then this guy
comes up he's like hi you asked me to
put reindeer antlers on this Mouse and I
can't superglue them to his head so what
should I do and he's like I'll just
staple him and she's like don't staple
reindeer antlers on a mouse don't do it
don't do it he's like oh Claire same as
always trying to save the world she's
not trying to save the world she's just
trying to make you not staple reindeer
antlers is that what saving the world is
to you not stapling things on animals
heads then you see the ghost of
Christmas past and he's a way more fun
actor than Phil Murray is in this I know
Scrooge is an unlikable guy but I mean
this has to hold our attention for two
hours you've got to put in some
redeeming qualities sometimes jerks can
be funny obviously
that's a dynamic character choice but
but put in this it's not thank you oh my
god movie saved it's Carol Kane as ghost
of Christmas present she's delightful of
this it's totally a character that I
identify with totally character I would
get cast as it's like this fairy but
who's also really menacing ghost of
Christmas future is also awesome he
comes and shows him what will happen if
he continues this way obviously we all
know this it's the Scrooge story I
really love what they do with the
computer screen of the Christmas future
ghosts uh super creepy the inside super
creepy love it the three ghosts are by
far the best part of this movie for me I
think they're interesting the acting is
really great even when they're not
acting with the ghost of Christmas
future it's still a dynamic interesting
character I love the sets the makeup the
effects of this movie I think that some
of the retelling of the screw story is
interesting I just I just feel like most
of it wasn't as fun as it couldn't be
his realization seeing where he comes to
and he's like I gotta change things
finally finally find me a little fun I
love when he does the whole like ruining
of the whole special and is on live TV
telling people what they should do for
Christmas but even in that he has
Elliott holding a gun to like all of the
control panel people and also has the
person that was gonna replace him he
just loses his job so that's cool
lots of lessons learned player still
deserves better
I know a lot of people like this I think
this is another one where like this just
mean 87 question mark it was a different
time of film where I'm not used to that
tone of comedy and
Oh get it way over my head brah the
farad said will you please for the love
of God stop the god damn hammering I
think you'll like it
it's freaky at times especially the
ghosts but it's got heart okay I so in
the hammering part I felt like Bill
Murray I would just like to see him play
like a heartfelt character for an entire
film
what are those films what should i watch
guide me show me the light because in
this he's just yelling and his yelling
doesn't really transfer to good acting
for me in my mind when I see this I
don't think it I don't believe it it
didn't seem real to me and and I know
that people are gonna hate this
the movie having heart I guess at the
end if I have to sit through an hour and
40 minutes a film till I get to the
heart I don't really want to see that
film oh you'll love the ghosts
especially Carol Kane I did love the
ghosts and Carol Payne obviously was my
favorite but they were the best part of
this film
Bill Murray does what Bill Murray does
also both his brothers are in the movie
his younger brother plays the brother
and his older brother plays the dad and
Christmas past part of the movie I did
not know that that's cool I liked
I love this movie love it love it love
it love it I think he will enjoy the
overall concept it might be put off by
the dark stuff for me as someone who saw
this when they were 5 years old I just
thought the world of this it is one of
the best adaptations I love them I love
it you love this film and I don't want
me not loving this film to put anyone
off on this film for them to be like wow
Tamra is the worst I love things that
other people don't love and and and
that's awesome
I'm so glad you love this I wasn't put
off by the dark stuff at all I love dark
things in movies I love I love love love
them and I think that that you shot when
you should have been at five years old I
think I waited too long to see this and
and my comedy palette is different now
because I waited so long to see a lot of
these films but it wasn't for me and
that's okay you were gonna wonder about
that feed me Seymour line at the end
fact-checked richard donner love him
ad-lib and he just rambled I was
wondering about the feed me Seymour
alliant because I love that musical and
it had it didn't make any sense reading
there but okay that's actually a great
movie enjoy you will love it I know
people love this and I don't hate me I
just it wasn't it wasn't my thing and
then the next week
Tara's never seen was cancelled no I I
love the people loved this even though
it's not my thing I love that it is some
other people's things
next week I'm watching It's a Wonderful
Life I hope you all don't hate me by
then thank you so much for watching I'll
see you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
you